elle a pour titre à ciel
ouvert la jeunesse actuelle est celle
celle de tous les
temps pas de problème les cœurs sont des
ailes pour qu'il les
comprend pour qu'il va bien c'est facile
pourtant d'être de son époque et de
l'avoir pété son printemp ça n qui
choque la fenesse actuelle est celle qui
vit en chantant
ah ciel ouvert à cheveux des fa à bouche
gourmande vois revenenir le temps joli
du
soleil le temps d'aimer la vie en
fleurou demande le temps de battre avec
son cœur le réveil et surtout mes amis
cyez pas par ceux qui disent que l'amour
grand amour est un
péché car souvent en moral leur envie se
déguise et ces jaloux vousai vous
empêcher de vivre en ciel ouvert à bleu
d'azur à cloche qui danse à rêve la nuit
à saute le jour au soleil
ah ciel ouvert à cheveux les Fas Jois
immense à loin des pions à liberté goû
du jour
plong dans l'eau à quel pays à vive la
France à crise de rire à M folie à
amours et surtout mes amis pensez pas à
l'automne biena bien attend tout comme
l'hiver profitez au contraire du bonheur
que vous vous donne les vrais beau jours
sous les grands arbres verts entés en
dan à teint de feu à chante loisirs à
grandes vacances vivez vos jeux à craque
désir à ciel ouvert à craque désir à
ciel
[Musique]
ouvert